5 25 on your wednesday morning well the
big squeeze is getting even shiftier
ahead of more bridge demolition this is
all part of the ongoing 40 million
dollar i-515 viaduct rehabilitation
project got a bunch of lane restrictions
ramp closures been going on all week
going to continue to the rest of the
week they are all on ndot's website
i515project.com
now the bigger part of the story is
monday's demolition of the northbound 95
515 bridge over eastern that means a
nine-day closure of eastern under the
freeway now southbound drivers on the 95
515 you're now using that those
reconstructed lanes from last year's
demolition of that part of the freeway
now that experience is any indication
the upcoming demolition and restrictions
should go fairly smoothly and that
includes suggested detours for north and
south on travel while eastern is closed
that is bonanza or stuart over to
maryland parkway with local business
access on eastern still open and all of
this information along with all of our
stories on our 8newsnow.com website
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something driving to
crazy email me traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com